i
agree with you i'm working on a man give
me another five days
all right so it's another three days
from now we'll see what happens on that
but
again one of those rare events where the
president was cornered by protesters on
what's happening at the border of crisis
that he does not define as a crisis but
he promises to address within a matter
of days we shall see ron vettel joins us
for another retired
acting ice director ron what did you
think of that
well it's just a a situation that we're
in
publicly there's this crisis on the
border and you have a certain segment of
the population those protesters
that want to remove the resources that
the department of homeland security
needs to help solve this problem and so
you know shutting down detention is not
going to make the problems at the border
better it's not going to protect the
homeland
those are necessary resources that's why
they're in inventory
and to suggest that we could do without
them or that we're going to end them
it just it makes no sense to me at all
you know we're learning a little bit
more about the cut and funding for the
border wall
that the biden administration had
included in its skinny budget in other
words that's
not included in that skinny budget but
that he had uh
specifically cancelled all border wall
projects that were paid for
uh with diverted military funds that
that was a rationale
for doing so what did you make of that
well that's less resources that's less
capability on the border
i would urge this administration to help
the men and women of cbp
specifically the border patrol as it
relates to the wall there are there are
known gaps in the construction projects
that exist right now and i would urge
them to close those gaps when i was a
chief
in rio grande valley we had put up the
wall and we
intended to put gates in certain areas
and the funding
and the resources and the lawsuits
prevented us from closing those gaps
and that's manpower intensive you have
to have somebody guarding those gaps
24 7 because that's a natural entry
point for folks and so i would urge them
to shore up the gaps where the 18 foot
barrier has
you know if you have 18 foot barrier on
the right and the left you got to close
up that gap otherwise
you're going to be wasting valuable
agent time
to just sit and watch that opening in
the in the wall
um ron how important is it to you as
someone who you know was a former border
patrol chief to see the president or the
vice president for that matter
at the border to go and visit these
facilities
well it means a great deal to the
workforce even at my level when we went
out and visited with
the men and women who were on the front
line and asked them what their needs
were
ask them what their challenges were and
then i could take that back to
washington and work with my staff to try
to meet those needs
um and then there's this whole morale
boost that comes with it you you have
somebody
you know in authority in the government
that that's in your chain of command
including the president that knows what
you do and is eager to
understand it and then provide resources
and provide
uh information and get his staff to plan
to shore up these gaps
to help you know ameliorate this crisis
i think it would be very valuable for
them to do
you know it's not much we know about the
human trafficking part of this
outside of this development this past
week where 90 people were found in a
houston home look like
any home in any idyllic neighborhood in
this country
90 people were crowded in there um what
did you make of it and and the fact that
maybe
what's been happening at the border is
is
is what triggered it well that that's a
symptom you know this is a symptom of
what happens when the border is in chaos
right
these 90 people were smuggled into the
houston area imagine if you lived on
that street
imagine your kids riding their bikes
back and forth along that block
how dangerous that is for for
neighborhoods and then those people 90
people in a small
family home um probably being extorted
probably being human trafficked and if
you've got 90 people who have just
crossed the border illegally there's at
least a handful of them that are there
that have criminal records
um and so it's an unsafe and unsanitary
condition for those individual migrants
to be in but it's also a danger to that
community and it's an example of what
happens
when we don't have sufficient resources
and control at the border
all right now i do know the
administration will tap the agriculture
department to provide
personnel to help i don't know
specifically if it's going to be at the
border iran we just hear
up to 500 individuals i'm i'm not sure
those who
work at the agriculture department ever
signed up for that but what do you what
do you make of it
yeah this was done before in the 2014
surge as well
you're looking for government employees
because they're cleared and they have
known backgrounds so that they could
interact and help alleviate some of the
the uh the shelters or the border patrol
spaces right
so they can do things that help care and
comfort for these migrants that are in
custody
you know rolling back this policy and
not having sufficient resources at the
border
it's going to go down as a mistake it
you know to say that it's getting better
okay fine they've moved more migrants
out of border patrol custody last month
and into hhs care but
not having sufficient shelter space and
reversing the policy without
and knowing that that was going to be
the result um it's just a big mistake
and
unfortunately it's the men and women of
cdp and their families that have to go
through this stress
and they're the ones that are at the
front line that see the bulk of this
problem it's their
they can't say no to this traffic when
an unaccompanied minor comes up to an
immigration officer
whether a cbpo or a border patrol agent
they have to take them into custody
that's the law there's no
there's no option there if there's no
space at hhs that it just continues to
back up
and they've done better but it's nowhere
near to where it needs to be